pour faire un bon aligot pour les cinq
ou six kilos de pommes de terre invite
les 3 5 g de beurre 1 kg de tom vous
incorporez un peu d'ail et un peu de la
fondue et un peu de grain
quand vous avez fait une bonne purée
vous incorporez d'un tome fraîche et
vous remuez pour obtenir un feat
remuez jusqu'à ce que cela l'atom soit
bien fondu après on va encore hélas la
crème un peu d'ail et un peu dollar
oui la ligue cela dépend des faillites
ont été faits sur l'aubrac par les
bergers ceux qui soignent et les bêtes
qui savait que sa main j'ai presque de
porno t1 de la ligue au beurre fromage
aux recettes toute la nourriture sur les
monts d'aubrac a diffusé lors on va
alors qu'une nourriture de montagne le
montagnard
pourquoi que ça a débuté par la menace a
été peut-être encore plus anciens je ne
sais rien mais anigo se manger beaucoup
dans les montagnes et dans les bureaux
en montagne à plus de bureau alors moi
je dis merci
[Musique]